ma vie dit au téléphone leur lente que
vous étiez disposés dans ce film a joué
le rôle de la vieille lesbienne mais
naturellement ne serait ce que parce que
c'est la vérité c'est-à-dire racontez
moi ce que vous entendez par là et bien
parce que dans ma vie j'ai été
entièrement est absolument lesbiennes et
vous employer le mot vieille lesbiennes
en effet j'ai trois quarts de siècle sur
les épaules moore nat ligne et pour les
femmes se place à peu près à l'âge où
met-on 14 ou 15 ans à 28 ans j'ai
rencontré lettres avec lequel je devais
passer le reste de ma vie la mort seuls
nous a séparés
il est évident que je subsiste jeu
subsiste sans élan ce qui a été nous
vous en doutez excessivement dur
elle était homosexuel elle l'était de
goût profondément elle m'a dit que ayant
senti en elle impérativement depuis
toujours un goût profond pour les femmes
elle a voulu essayer de s'en évader ou
tout au moins de le localiser de
connaître autre chose d'être comme tout
le monde parce qu'il sent la normale ça
n'est pas les femmes
c'est une occupation que vous même avez
eu d'être comme tout le monde et d'avoir
le goût des sommes absolument pas parce
que pour moi ça m'a jamais effleuré
vous n'avez jamais curiosité ou alors
lorsque j'avais une douzaine d'années ou
13 ans peut-être 10 à vide et déjà deux
garçons du lycée voisin
bon ça c'est bon mais disons pour aller
jusqu'au bout quelques attouchements qui
m'ont tellement peu enthousiasmés et
plus j'ai eu aucun mal à y renoncer
le problème ne s'est pas posé pour moi
le jour je suis parti de chez moi pour
participer au tournage
je me suis demandé comment seraient
toutes ces femmes que j'allais
rencontrer en quoi il me serait
semblable différentes
[Musique]
pour vous c'est un choix leur sexualité
aux biens je vous réponds que c'est un
choix où ça a été vendu qu'à demander
une démarche
dans un an je peux dire que c'est au
choix d'une certaine façon
historiquement pour toi
question difficile à lui tout seul choix
à travers une personne ce roman mais je
ne voyais pas en tant que choix fixé sur
sur la sexualité par exemple priseur
vous indiquez soit déjà plus pour nos
belges avaient pu très nombreuses et
mieux quelqu'un et je dois bien vous
pour préciser que ça a été en mise en
relation de très satisfaisante et que
mon désir des femmes est venu à ses
torts mais de manière très impérieuse et
que j'ai décidé dans un esprit tout à
fait je dirais libertaire si on peut
dire ça de deux temps de l'expérience
mais c'était aussi un choix de personnes
[Musique]
à laver notre génération de fans à
évoluer et à mon avis n'a pas évolué
avec donc il ya pour moi et à mon âge un
choix restreint pour moi la recherche
lui-même était très troublante très très
tôt ce même corps qui m'a toujours
attiré je voulais effectivement me
fondre en lui savoir ce qui se passait à
l'intérieur puisque ça se passait en
moins et que dans cette attirance j'ai
découvert que l'autre en tant qu'autre
m'était très présent même si c'était le
même c'est-à-dire une femme alors que
j'avais le sentiment mais très très
confus et c'est maintenant à postériori
d'ailleurs ce que je l'analyse est que
je le dis qu'avec un homme il y avait
toujours cette source de conflits avec
les fils du conflit mais des filtres est
très sournois d'ailleurs pas la guerre
ouverte dont on parle beaucoup
actuellement mais quelque chose qui
était de l'ordre du conflit et que
l'autre je ne le voyais pas j'avais
envie de le voir entendre comme
spécifiquement aux mais que ça a été
très difficile
c'est ça que je pourrais dire que
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire que c'est pas le reflet ni les
miroirs mais que c'est cet autre qui
sort en une femme qui me troublait
m'intéresse beaucoup
je refuse je crois les étiquettes c'est
à dire que si on m'avait dit quand je
vivais avec un homme est au bout
hétérosexuels j'aurais eu la même
difficulté répondent je suis brune et
sexuelle terre très large pour une vie
qui n'auraient pas de structure codifié
on peut dire par la culture c'est à dire
que c'est l'impulsion de mes désirs de
mai
les choix de des choses que ma tête des
mails et en même temps que mon corps
impose qui font que j'ai une relation
lors je peux dire que que je suis
ouverte c'est tout ce que je peux dire à
tous disponibles c'est ça que je peux
répondre
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
où
[Musique]
mais j'ai pris conscience de mon
homosexualité à ses terres ça n'a pas
tellement poser problème dans mon milieu
familial est-ce que tu as tes parents le
sable j'ai eu du mal à leur dieu parce
que j'avais peur de réactions j'ai peur
d'une juste part de quoi ensuite
il m'a dit ça passerait à son nom
où
si tu te trouve en face de l'amour que
tu éprouves pour quelqu'un tu n'as pas
peur de la réaction que tu vas trouver
en face de toi tu peux va pas vers
l'action si je déclare quelque chose je
déclare pas souvent mais c'est la
réaction que tu crains qui t'empêche de
deux déclarations que je crains la
réaction importe plus tard
[Musique]
un enfant c'est à cette unique et
quelquefois guitl disions dans ce format
désir d'un enfant
il déjà là l'enfant ça c'est déjà une
chose mais ça car bourg s'appelle
rapport avec le mot si mon père a pas
avec nos sexualités dire si j'avais
d'abord on a faim là je prendrai malware
toute façon mais déjà la fin je peux la
voir
je voulais seulement je crois que j'ai
lus par rapport à ça j'ai d'autres
d'autres 26 ans mais à notre niveau ça
te paraît pas comment tu vois je suis
dit que j'ai pas vraiment le désir de la
femme est profondément lié à l'amour que
je peux avoir pour quelqu'un que pour
une femme et je me sers varient d'un
grand désespoir à l'idée que de femmes
ne trouvent pas voir l'enfant sens
une sorte de tristesse
est ce que tu as des amis en jamais pas
mal et je perds des ailes je peux même
avoir à faire des gestes de tendresse
envers un homme que j'aime beaucoup et
de sexualité
tu refuses complètement le la sexualité
entre guillemets absolument c'est tout
ce que je refuse de
tu trouve qu une seule
quand on naît homosexuel on n'est pas
plus mal que si on monte au ciel
bon c'est vrai
soit
[Musique]
il
m
et
[Musique]
je suis monté à paris pour rejoindre un
groupe de femmes que je ne connaissais
pas c'est marianne gosset qui avait
organisé notre rencontre
c'est au musée de moi j'ai envie de
manger des avants avec des petits
oignons pour aller pour la salle
messieurs vous me donnez 100 france de
sang
de même s'il vous plaît
merci enfin
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
moi j'aime bien les hommes et j'aime
bien les femmes alors ça dépend
quelquefois je mange et je vis avec un
homme j'ai une petite fille d'ailleurs
et pour moi la l'harmonie parfaite entre
guillemets serait justement de pouvoir
vivre avec un homme et avec une femme
mais malheureusement c'est assez
difficile problème de temps problèmes
d'abord de l'investissement d'énergie et
c'est raté
mais pour moi la femme est très très
important enfin je peux pas vivre
seulement avec un homme est en fait j'ai
eu une liaison avec une femme bon bah
fixe a peut être avec d'autres femmes
mais ça fait partie de ma vie
c'est vraiment c'est comme dans un
puzzle sont de petits morceaux qui
s'assemblent qui s'assemble j'ai une
femme
on peut trouver une beaucoup plus grande
complicité
une communication énorme je crois que
c'est vraiment important à dire ce qu'on
ne trouve pas avec avec un homme la
fameux plus ya pas de limite
j'ai l'impression bon ça c'est tout à
fait personnel j'ai l'impression que
c'est beaucoup moins limitée qu'un homme
un homme c'est assez assez simple c'est
pas péjoratif quand je donne ce mot
simple alors que la femme on a toujours
l'impression qu'on a du temps pour la
découvrir on a du temps il ya c -
brusquer
[Musique]
c'est par la notion de temps quand je
suis avec une femme est complètement
différente qu'avec un homme
oui mais je crois que cette complicité
elle vient de l'oppression parce que je
crois que la seule chose que nous avons
en commun c'est l'oppression
ça c'est juste que nous avons en commun
de particuliers on oublie toujours de
dire que les hommes en fait sont
emprisonnés dans une forme d'oppression
aussi qui consiste dès le départ décline
s dans leur éducation à se taire à tout
garder pour eux à être forts devant les
événements se sont sont des êtres qu'on
destine à être responsable être être
capable d'assumer seul tout ce qui peut
arriver dans la vie et je crois que
justement le fait qu'il y ait moins de
complicité je pense en train d' homme et
une femme vient de là
la seule idée qui me soient restés de
cette discussion c'est que
l'homosexualité féminine serait une
réaction à l'oppression masculine
je n'étais pas vraiment d'accord avec
cette idée nous aurions dû analyser de
plus près et aussi définir l'oppression
seul hier si je l'avais regardée plus
longtemps ils m'auraient donné la
nostalgie de mes moutons
j'étais mariée j'ai eu un homme et je
les ai faits chargée à rien du tout
enfin je me suis changé moi parce que
moi j'ai pris mon indépendance
j'ai appris à penser par moi même j'ai
appris à faire plein de choses par
moi-même et à vivre pour moi mais j'ai
plus rien fait changer mon mari du tout
ça
sa mentalité l'avait puig leila garder
mais tu as pas peur de ce ghetto enfin
de que justement les les femmes se
renferme sur el fassi tu veux sur le
problème est que bon on met les hommes à
part bon il ya des hommes et des femmes
même si toi tu décides de vivre avec une
femme tu tu rencontres dans ton travail
je ne sais pas à des dîners dans ta vie
sociale et privée tu rencontres des
hommes
tu as pas tellement envie d'avoir
une sorte de
des changes avec eux d'essayer de ça
t'intéresse pas j'ai des échanges avec
les hommes et beaucoup jeu mais je ne
vis pas avec eux c'est tout mais j'ai
des échanges a pas que militante
moi je ne suis pas que lesbienne je suis
tout un tas de choses entre temps je
suis
mais je suis syndicaliste je suis
militant politique je suis militante
je suis tout un tas de choses mais donc
en faisant tout ça je rencontre lui
demandé aux ong des camarades pour mal
aux hommes ce sont des camarades et je
suis leur égal j'ai rien de tout je suis
ni moi ni plus que je suis leur égal
mais j'ai pas du tout envie de faire
avancer les zones autrement c'est tout
[Musique]
à
m
je parie
[Musique]
une amie
pas
à
et
je vais souvent dans les boîtes pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
j'aime beaucoup dansé ya aussi le fait
que je suis obligé enfin je vais
obligatoirement dans les boîtes
homosexuels parce que dans les autres
boîtes je suis tout de suite emmerder ça
devient intolérable c'est pour ça qu'on
a des années avant de connaître les
boîtes homosexuels je n'allais pas en
boîte en fait
et dès que j'ai connu les belote
homosexuel je vivais très souvent mais
je les choisis parce que il y en a c'est
de la soupe quoi c'est du commerce
moi je voulais seulement dire que
l'atmosphère est beaucoup l'atmosphère
parce qu'on s'y amuse bien c'est vrai
fou c'est on s'y sent bien et il n'y a
pas tout de suite cette atmosphère de
drague on est regardés à la misère
homosexuel est telle que les femmes et
il ya un tel ghetto que les femmes
vivent dans des boîtes et c'est fait
pour cela
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'elles sont
si chers et moi je trouve ça alors là
pas chouette du tout c'est absolument
horrible
est-ce que j'ai combattu chez les hommes
je le combattrai aussi chez les femmes
mon problème c'est que justement je suis
avec une femme et que mes amis
hétérosexuels veulent absolument
considérer qu'on est un couple bon ça
c'est inacceptable parce que l'on
conduit pas ensemble on s'entend très
bien mais on
ne vit pas dans le même appartement et
en plus de ça il va absolument que cet
ami sous le fasse l'homme
il va la considérer comme un homme et
moi comme la femme servile qui la suit
comme un petit chien
alors j'ai ma personnalité et il n'est
pas question que que je l'abandonnent
par exemple ce que j'ai décidé
d'annoncer partout que j'étais
homosexuel parce que je voulais rentrer
pour mon isolement
mais mes collègues ont tout de suite
après demander comment oser et est ce
que c'est vrai qu'on avait des
instruments et puis alors là aussi il ya
le rapport homme femme qui sait qu'il a
fait la femme et que ce qui fait l'homme
et donc il faut constamment constamment
remettre remettre un jour cette idée que
il n'ya pas besoin d'homme pour s'aimer
et que si on n'a pas un phallus on ne
remplace pas par un autre c'est
exactement je pense ce qu'il faut dire
on ne peut plus penser en dehors du
couple
or les gens qui s'aiment n'ont pas
besoin de vivre ensemble ça devient
complètement aliénant c'est vrai mais
c'est pas c'est pas tous je veux dire
que des gens qui qui sème la limite ne
ne devrait pas dans le besoin de la
présence quotidienne de la côte est ce
que c'était c'est pas ça s'est passé à
vivre en couple et une idée complètement
fausse et du couple chez les hétéros
comme chez les homos et c'est vrai que
les copains homosexuels qui vivent en
couple en une certaine
un sentiment de sécurité et vivent comme
les autres et si on voit des couples en
amérique et se marie c'est pour ça c'est
pour être comme les autres ça n'a plus
rien de révolutionnaire d'être
homosexuel dans ces conditions là et moi
je dis qu'être que d'être homosexuel
c'est d'être c'est une vie autrement
c'est qu'une vie révolutionnaire il
faudrait mettre fin cette idée de
détruire l'idée de complémentarité je
crois que c'est ça qui est allié n'a en
fait une bonne complémentarité penser
que deux personnes ont nécessairement
besoin d'être ensemble en fait mon avis
qu'il faudrait rechercher qu'on soit
homosexuel ou hétérosexuel ou n'importe
quoi c'est l'autonomie et c'est
simplement quand on est autonome qu'on
peut bien vivre avec les autres
je vais vous dire j'ai eu une preuve
extraordinaire de l'assimilation de
notre couple un couple normal c'est une
brave femme du pays
une voisine qui était veuve le
surlendemain de l'enterrement de mon ami
me rencontrent m'embrasse et me dis
seulement ces mots à ma pauvre hollande
on est pareil à présent
d'après toi c'est une fille ou un garçon
mais tu sais d'après nos jeunes sur le
plateau
[Applaudissements]
cette fois ci ça s'est passé moins
violemment que d'habitude deux jours
plus tôt à la station de métro des eaux
à nos mairies qui pour savoir que c'est
une fille il faudrait mettre la main à
la braguette leur sexe ne mettait que
trop évident la dernière émission
télévision française sur l'amo sexualité
il y a eu immédiatement une répression
un pda et et virer de son boulot le
lendemain et comme par hasard c'était un
ouvrier et est évident que les grands
couturiers les écrivains n'ont
absolument aucun problème pour être
homosexuel au contraire qui n'a pas son
petit homosexuels chez soi c'est quelque
chose c'est très très bien dans notre
monde libéral et là aussi c'est la
politique c'est à dire qu'être
homosexuel quand on est ouvrière
ouvriers ouvriers ouvrière moi même je
travaille dans un bureau
ce n'est pas facile
[Applaudissements]
ça m'amuse beaucoup quand on me dit
l'homosexualité c'est quelque chose de
bourgeois parce qu'on fait en fin de
compte on ne voit que cela parce que eux
ils peuvent vivre à l'extérieur mais les
gens les gens ce qui doit guider pendant
leur travail et est rémunéré par un
salaire et d'un patron peuvent pas de
tout vivre leur amour au grand jour
[Musique]
bonjour marianne un bon jour car si mal
être oui entre je ne me vois pas non je
crois vivre avec quelqu'un ici alors je
me dirai si si quelqu'un un jour si une
femme joueurs avaient envie de venir
vivre avec moi ici je serai très
bouleversée parce que je crois qu'il
faudrait être folle pour venir vivre
avec moi ici la vie que je mène parfois
le pas dans un sens très pendant 500
instance mauvais mais enfin
dans un sens péjoratif mais il faudra
vraiment mais c'est impossible il ya des
jours je pense que c'est impossible
lundi jour je crois je me demande est ce
c'est pour ça pour cette impossibilité
cette impossibilité là que je ressens
que je me demande si justement cette
distanciation n'est pas juste pour moi
que je prends pas ma solitude c'est un
instinct de conservation une survie mais
que que j'assume à la fois que je désire
volontairement parce que autrement
quand on se trouve devant l'absurdité
qu'on peut que point qu'on peut qu'on
peut trouver à la vie la quantité de
désespoir qui peut en émane et on n'a
plus qu'une chose à faire c'est mourir
je crois oui mais oui mais on peut aimer
oui certainement et je me demande si si
aimer quelqu'un qui ne vous aime pas
c'est pas mourir un peu
mounir à petit feu et puis si aimer
quelqu'un qui vous aime c'est pas non
plus dans le sens où vous avez un trop
plein de deux bonnes heures de plaisir
qui éclate après un moment de 2,2 de
dépression pour moi c'est très peu
dissociable de la mort est en fait la
vie de solitude que je mène pour moi
serait symbole de vie
[Musique]